[Music]
what what you guys do yeah to make money
whatever you guys do thank you baby
I gotta stop doing that I'm just gonna
eat them no you should have a fans only
account it's all it fans only fans Julie
you're such a Christian girl look at you
you're good Christian girl doesn't even
know the site I don't know some people
were telling me I should start wine and
then I was even think is like [ __ ] would
you more money would you join you I no
idea what would you do on it yeah what
would you do is that think do you would
love to know who yeah you make so much
money
dude did you know on popular porn
searches Julia Child pops up no that
might be but guess what please on for
each state for each state they show a
pornhub search of what is the most liked
typed right in almost all of the West
Coast like going from Texas on to the
West is Asian yes so you are a hot
commodity
and guess what Florida is boats yeah
don't [ __ ] what do you mean they [ __ ]
on the boat or it's just a search term
it's a search term right yes it's boats
I was like what the [ __ ] so Mike no
wonder all my [ __ ] videos come up as
boat also skips are hoverboards but yeah
interesting Asian did you know that wow
if you are I'm pretty damn sure if you
went into porn you make all along Oman
are dude I'm not utilizing what I'm
giving Julie you can even just
[ __ ] you're not only fans probably
people love that [ __ ] yes Jenna you can
probably sell like a dirty [ __ ] sock
make Monday you get out with thumbnail
where you're like Julia fingering and
then they finger blast me [ __ ] out of
your nose do you still think double
penetration so I'm saying Julia does DP
I need to dip it in Lube first any like
sorry mom
that I have very supportive friends in
my life you want to see a cream pie okay
just [ __ ] everything that Julia's
knows she just Fox her nose up damn
someone's joking to that alright so for
everyone in the room what would you do
to make money if you were paralyzed mute
and deaf oh [ __ ]
paralyzed mute and deaf well what I what
can you type waste up actually website
oh good type oh hell yeah
I could I could do online job you're
paralyzed from the waist up or wake up
you can't type so you cannot type yeah
well unless you figure out with your
toes wait so you can walk up type like
this well you can walk well no your body
the hip movement I didn't know hip
movement I guess you're bound to a
wheelchair
no chair your feet work your knees work
but everything up beyond that it doesn't
work so you and your death and mute and
mute mutants you can't speak right yeah
that's worse than Stephen Hastings good
yeah I'll paint with my feet pair of
their feet yeah hang with you're feeling
like the on the side of the road type of
guy and like the big cities and you see
them painting and you yeah yeah I'll do
something like that yeah
yeah sure why be you guys death mu
Deveny
maybe I'll do like oh god I don't know
about okay how do you communicate
exactly the first thing for like any
type of work is typically communication
from YouTube you don't need it what your
own content or you can just do like the
video can't do that what you do is you
do with your feet okay tell me what you
gonna do good by your death yeah that's
what I'm saying is in order to
communicate you need a point of
communication whether it's verbal or
physical but they have software to do
that now right right but what is gonna
control the software is it through the
brain or is it through a toe or like
eyes you put your balls
which is the [ __ ] all the time mashing
baby we have a tire and then they put
[ __ ] on their it and then they smash who
drives it but I'm not saying it's the
car but I'm just saying you don't need
to communicate on those and something
along those lines where maybe he's there
would be they're smashing [ __ ] with
their feet and not that [ __ ] up I know
by that what Joel is trying to get at is
who what is control to know that's
communicate that's the first point of
communication is like you have to
control your body somehow to bridge that
gap okay so now the bridge is opened
right so it's like now from the tow or
do you go next I don't know use their
eyes to control software a lot I've seen
it so we have two options okay I see
where you're saying yeah yeah so if you
if you're paralyzed and you can only use
your eyes then you can work online jobs
mmm
you could be a writer even you can try
it sure you can okay do you think a
bunch of those surveys true I could be a
lifeguard no no no roll it back roll the
bag I've got a lifeguard tower right
okay and I'm just got my eyes searching
the beach what do you do there's a
string to a bell you can't move your
mouth you can all do use your kids
Johnny what do you do you only have your
I hope to have the stream taped to my
eyes in eighteen and nineteen year old
in Brazil has figured it all out for his
life this is what he's gonna do to make
money in Brazil as a mute deaf end half
paralyzed person damn he has a big booty
where's he at
all right there on the right okay oh
yeah he's [ __ ] wait a minute
don't go with his feet in a wheelchair
he's gonna be found really quick oh my
gosh this was a [ __ ] gangster dude no
excuses he's like you can still rob
people [ __ ] off [ __ ] your excuses so I
was trying to say it live such a good
[ __ ] setup
he's charming he'll live
that was taking mine [ __ ] went
like this and he doesn't even need to
talk he cocked it - that's crazy like
this
yeah and then you use the other one to
[ __ ] it yeah what's up well hey see you
[ __ ] me up man cuz I was trying to
think of like [ __ ] to make money and
then you guys are awesome you guys are
really hoping to save lots on you all me
we're two PC guys pretty good I don't
know what I did
has he ever really pulled the trigger
with this tolls though cuz I just
pictured that going on and his [ __ ]
feet flying behind his head how did he
hold the gun with one foot I have no
idea wish there was like a close-up and
a clearer image of how he did it
well how about also you know make fun
but the escape wouldn't be too great
yeah the shopkeeper was like it would
have been impossible for this guy to get
away cuz obviously he didn't get away
but there's two people right here so
homie - no that was actually a customer
so there's three even take them
seriously I thought that was his homie
but the shopkeeper was like basically
like there's I mean you're robbing me
but there's no way to carry anything I
mean I could put it up but you're just
your thing when he goes so fast no and
like oh it's all so then like okay
hypothetically right if the money is on
his lap is they still gonna have the gun
and then just like wheelchair backwards
out the door you know and then he also
has to [ __ ] go breathe there's so
many opportunities for the shopkeeper to
get his money back
wait how was it controlling that thing
if his foots not working there's a
control on them so he actually lewd use
a hat maybe a finger maybe no it looks
like from one place to another it looked
like at a remote on the honest foot
pedal or hand like this he was using his
hand dude like this yeah no I
using his foot because then as soon as
he finished cocking the gun
yeah then he put one foot down and then
he like moved over to like the side I'm
sorry but I can't take any criminal
seriously and even if he gets outside
you know you were talking about like
there's curbs sorts of situations they
you know he's got a getaway
he's Brazil 88 compliant I don't think
so I don't think so but even sidewalks
this is the note that he sent to the
shopkeeper he was inside the shop for
about 10 minutes just kind of there and
then eventually he gave this to the shop
people which he obviously wrote with his
foot pretty good yeah yes yeah because
he's a 19 year old kid and this is his
handwriting
Menten with what a speak in Brazil what
degree is Portuguese awesome now that's
enough yeah okay well good for him go to
jail yeah yeah cop do you usually go to
jail I went to jail I would have put him
in jail I think that why the criminal is
a crime as a crime as a crime is a crime
as a crime it's a crime with to cry but
sometimes they don't deserve time I
think he's doing time already I know
right yeah I like what drives a dude and
like that you know it's like that means
like shouldn't they be having like
government aid and all that stuff unless
he was already a criminal do you know
like when like in the mobsters when they
get into fights they're always like
putting some guy over the balcony so he
was one of the guys that actually fell
off drops was our barber kingster former
gangster got paralyzed and so can you
still game yeah so he can't really get
government aid because he can only
report that I got thrown off a balcony
so he's back at it again I don't know
there's just certain people of the
population that I find zero threatened
like this guy maybe a shopkeeper thought
he was joking effort exactly right like
a hundred and five year old grandma she
came up with a shotgun
it's just I'm sorry man I don't want you
to go hungry you're probably doing this
because you're you need money alright I
pity you yeah just like here you go
you remember how humans are right if you
if he was to rig his chair up with so
many [ __ ] guns on it and he goes in
the store I don't think anyone's not
taken seriously yeah it's like holy [ __ ]
okay whatever you want you've got a
little battle tank or whatever he had a
rocket launcher oh he didn't make it
look threatening out what if he had
spikes everywhere that'd be sick -
that's so sick maybe he's saving up for
that dude okay he's gotta start
somewhere
you got to start with the first job yeah
we need a Scarface like this I'm down a
movie yeah oh my god wouldn't you speak
he can't even say say hello to my little
friend oh maybe you'll be robotic well I
didn't think okay and consider that
robot like Steven Hawkings the trailer
means the generals because no I know but
like he has two fingers that he talks
with right yeah yeah so maybe in this
thing we'll figure something out and
it'll be the speaking smell voice cheese
yeah this guy's awesome yeah deaf to say
you can't hear the COS so in design well
can you read lips tone see I think you
turning me all the time just to make
sure he's covered every angle
but you can't hear footsteps of behind
him what I think what if he got away and
then they had to get a lineup of
everyone who was there so they got a
bunch of people who worked in the area
and they just got him in his chair [ __ ]
he's like you know and it was like who
is it could be the guy are you like
going and doing that thanks for watching
on patreon everybody this has been a
patreon being if I ever heard of one of
my whole life the bad guy dude he's
doing bad [ __ ] if he was a good guy do
it we'd be like wow that is [ __ ]
honorable what's your excuse you lazy
ass you know but he's not I do think
that people who aren't Robin are lazy
asses compared to this guy I'm just very
proud that he's out there - he's a
go-getter yeah so you guys like to make
fun of the handicapped no way I'm not
making fun of the handicapped here I'm
like dude you go there and you get yours
man no he's getting ours he's not
getting his he's getting ours cuz he's
stealing well sometimes I feel like
people with disabilities are allowed to
do things that were not allowed to do I
don't call him Andy got unlike you
because I truly love the handicapped I
call them a handi-capable you're you oh
I'm gonna call them candy cane then [ __ ]
that cat they're handicapped I call them
human beings actually